حصون للاثرياء وملجا لاغنياء العالم
لطالما كانت سويسرا بنك العالم وصاحبه
النظام المصرفي الانجح والاكثر استقرارا
حتى جاءت ازمه بنك كريديسوس التي هزت تلك
الصوره
الازمه انطلقت يوم الخميس الماضي عندما
بدا العملاء بسحب ودائعهم لتنخفض اسهم
البنك بنسبه مخيفه وتبلغ سالب 5.48
ليرفع البنك الرايه الحمراء
الانهيار بدا يوم الخميس ولم تنتظر
السلطات السويسريه حتى انتهاء عطله نهايه
الاسبوع
لتوفر اكثر من 150 مليار دولار
الحل الامثل وربما الوحيد كان شراء كريدوس
من قبل بنك اخر ليكون المنافس يو بي اس هو
من يستحوذ عليه البنك الوطني السويسري
ووزير الماليه وهيئه الاشراف على السوق
الماليه
تدخلوا بالسرعه القصوى مقدمين خيارين لا
ثالث لهما شراء
او تركه يعلن افلاسه والذي سيهوي بالبنوك
الاخرى مثل قطع الدومينو لينتهي الامر
بانهيار النظام المصرفي بالكامل
البنك الوطني السويسري باقراض بنك كريدي
سويس حجما كبيرا من السيوله وهذا الدعم
بعيد المدى يؤمن الوقت اللازم لايجاد حل
للحفاظ على الاستقرار المالي افلاس مصر
فكريدي سويس له عواقب وخيمه على الاستقرار
المالي الوطني والدولي والاقتصاد السويسري
لطالما كانت سويسرا البنك الامنه للعالم
تعتمد نظاما مصرفيا مدروسا ومستقرا ومع
اقتراب كريدي سويس من حافه الافلاس لم يكن
الخوف على البنك فقط بل على مكانه سويسرا
وانهيار نموذجها الاقتصادي المتين والذي
تعتمده الدوله المحايده بشكل اساسي عمر
العربيه